tout de suite j'ai même cendres et qui
est sur place qui évolue aux côtés du
chef de l'état depuis depuis quelques
mois maintenant james e bonjour on a
suivi donc cette cette prise de parole
du président français est ce qu'on va
retenir c'est qu'il juge nécessaires de
nouvelles
discussions avec kiev les ukrainiens
qu'il appelle à négocier avec la partie
russe mais il ne dit pas pour autant il
ne confirme pas pour autant s'il va ou
non se rendre à kiev la question demeure
toujours
voilà la question demeure toujours mais
on a quand même un temps de sérieux
indices à c'est à dire que emmanuel
macron a donné deux à dix premiers il a
dit tout simplement je ne peux pas vous
donner les détails logistiques et il a
également dit qu'il fallait selon lui
que le temps politique était venu de se
rendre en ukraine il a dit qu'il fallait
faire ce voyage avant le sommet de
l'europe à venir le conseil de l'europe
et il a dit il a exposé les raisons pour
lesquelles selon lui il est temps de
venir le président a précisé que selon
lui il était temps d'avoir de nouvelles
discussions notamment en matière des
d'alevins financière et militaire il a
également dit qu'il était fallait
envoyer des signaux politiques très
clair il a dit également qu'il fallait
que ces signaux soit envoyé au niveau
européen effectivement comme vous l'avez
entendu seul dans ce sonore mais il a
martelé à au moins deux reprises selon
lui et bien voilà la russie il a dit
sous cette forme il a dit la russie est
aux portes de l'europe elle va rester
aux portes de l'europe c'est une
puissance dotée il a dit vous il faut
arriver à ce moment où l'élève le feu
cesse et on s'assoit autour de la table
de négociation il dit que la robe doit
avoir sa place autour de cette table de
négociation dont clairement un message
qui laisse entendre que tout cas le
président de la république a maintenant
clairement la volonté politique de se
rendre sur place en ukraine et il l'a
dit très clairement aujourd'hui voient
la volonté politique exprimée en en
saura probablement davantage dans les
heures qui arrivent en attendant il va
s'envoler maintenant direction la
moldavie prochaine étape 1
oui absolument la moldavie où il aura
rendez vous avec maya sandhu la
présidente élue en 2020 pour avoir des
discussions là notamment sur l'europe et
sur ce ce nouveau ce nouveau
groupe politique qui souhaitent créer
cette communauté politique européenne
qui engloberait tous les pays de
l'espace géographique européen
c'est-à-dire finalement créer une entité
qui permettrait de discuter à la fois
avec les pays de l'union européenne et
les pays qui sont à l'extérieur parce
qu'il faut le rappeler la moldavie
l'ukraine la géorgie souhaite accélérer
une procédure accélérée pour accéder à
l'union européenne mais le chef de
l'état l'a clairement laissé entendre et
cela est compliqué c'est que la
procédure pour accéder à l'union
européenne est longue et complexe elles
demandent des réformes importantes au
pays qui souhaitent le rejoindre et donc
l'idée de trouver un compromis politique
pour apporter du soutien envoyer un
message clair de dax et à venir à
l'union européenne tout en ne faisant
pas un accès direct car cela
compromettrait les statuts mêmes de
l'union et c'est tout ce numéro
d'équilibriste emmanuel macron va devoir
porter en moldavie pays qui est en
première ligne et pays qui a été
impactée très directement par la crise
les personnes qui ont dû fuir à les
réfugiés ukrainiens qui ont fui
l'ukraine sont arrivés en moldavie pays
qui a une faible population et qui a dû
prendre en compte un grand nombre de
personnes fuyant les combats en russie
alors qu'elle même est un risque d'être
déstabilisé notamment en raison de ce
territoire de la transnistrie qui est
contrôlée par des rebelles pro russe
merci